[Música]
vem como vocês podem ver as crianças
autistas não verbais são tão adoráveis e
amorosas como qualquer como todas as
outras crianças
as conseqüências da falta de interação e
da exclusão social por outro lado podem
ser brutais tanto nas vidas dela delas
quando a vida dos seus familiares ea
própria falta de conexão gera nas
pessoas uma é fazer com que as pessoas
subestimem a a a capacidade cognitiva
capacidade de interação que essas
pessoas têm mas isso pode mudar esse
livro aqui por exemplo traz um relato
que foi muito impactante da minha vida
ele conta a história de uma menina
autista carlos flashman que apenas aos
11 anos de idade conseguiu se comunicar
com o mundo pela primeira vez
ela estava num processo de fazer terapia
no dia da terapia eles perceberam que
ela estava muito agitada muito ansiosa e
ao invés de seguir o procedimento normal
de parar imagens com conceitos ela é
resolveu para surpresa de todos usar o
teclado e escreveu ajuda dente dói ou
seja é com isso ela mostrou a
importância da linguagem e o primeiro
contato na vida dela foi pra pedir
socorro socorro e pedir ajuda
a partir desse momento é baseado no
relato dos próprios pais na medida em
que ela foi construindo vou colar um
vocabulário foi que eles perceberam que
dentro dela havia uma pessoa articulada
inteligente que ele simplesmente não
conheci um certo
e de fato hoje em dia ela tem um blog
que é muito acessado e os relatos que
ela colocou nesse blog foram muito
importantes para nós é ter de
entendermos que grande parte da
dificuldade de conexão dos autistas com
o mundo se deve à hipersensibilidade
sensorial e há distorções que eles
sentem em sentidos como tato a visão e
audição
muitos artistas que está
nossa comunicação o que acabei de dizer
é que esse relato da causa do flash
indica que existem muitos autistas que
estão conscientes do mundo ao seu redor
querem interagir mas não conseguem
porque existe ruído na interface de
comunicação como excremento acabou de
ouvir e os ruídos do siri também foi
tudo armado certo e então é a pergunta é
na verdade esses relatos é despertar em
mim um otimismo muito grande é um caso
né que desperta otimismo - mas ao mesmo
tempo uma sensação muito profunda de
urgência é sobre o que fazer para
melhorar essa interface comunicação
diminuir esse ruído para que a gente
possa ver mais casos como esse dakar
flex acontecendo
é claro que é o primeiro passo é
entender como funciona a mente dos
autistas especificamente não verbais em
geral é muito freqüência é que autistas
não ver pais apresentem algum grau de
distúrbio do processamento auditivo o
que que é isso embora não sejam surdos
o som chega cheio de ruídos no cérebro
deles é o mesmo processo que gera ruídos
na entrada das informações também pode
gerar ruído quando o cérebro quer por
exemplo comandar a boca para articular
palavras o a mão para escrevê los ou
seja a quantidade de obstáculos de
orgânicos que os autistas têm para
desenvolver a linguagem e só um é enorme
e não só a linguagem na sua forma
expressa via é fala ou escrita
mas a linguagem também no seu uso para o
próprio pensamento
isso porque o cérebro que não
desenvolveu a linguagem ele usa imagens
e sensações para organizar os seus
próprios pensamentos mas não usam
palavras agora tenta vocês por alguns
instantes pensar em qualquer coisa sem
usar nenhuma palavra lá
difícil não é
inclusive eu quase por escutar daqui
algum esforço de alguns assim não pensa
em palavras
não penso em palavras isso porque o
nosso pensamento ele é inerentemente
estruturado e organizado pelas palavras
as palavras são ferramentas lógicas que
nos ajudam a organizar as informações
que chegam até nós as palavras nos
permite conversar com nós mesmos sobre
nossas experiências
agora imagina como é viver como é os
autistas não verbais que não tem esse
recurso a dificuldade cognitiva que que
isso impõe
além disso de uma maneira geral é se
sabe hoje em dia que o universo mental
universo interior dos autistas é um
universo muito intenso
isso é de acordo com esses relatos como
esse que eu acabei de escrever para
vocês e e de acordo com resultados
científicos de pesquisas feitos feitas
tanto com humanos quanto com modelos
animais que indicam que o cérebro dos
autistas é diferente eles possuem muito
mais interconexões entre os neurônios e
os neurônios são muito mais ativos
isso explica por exemplo a
hiperatividade explica as distorções
sensoriais e explica é fenômenos por
exemplo como é o caso da sinestesia as
decisiva é um fenômeno através do qual o
estilo de um de uma sensação que invade
o da outra no caso dos autistas
os sons forma formam imagens na região
do cérebro usada pela visão é como se os
autistas enxergassem os sons ou melhor
os sons interferem naquilo que os
autistas enxergam
então diante tudo isso é o que nós
podemos fazer para diminuir a distância
entre as nossas mentes e as mentes dos
autistas bem eu creio que existem dois
caminhos complementares para isso o
primeiro caminho é no sentido de
aproximar ele de nós diminuindo tentando
diminuir a super ativa idade neuronal
deles usando canabidiol
um composto derivado da cannabis é para
tentar reduzir então a hiperatividade e
outros sintomas relacionados com o
excesso da situação nacional é ataques
de nervosismo é e distúrbios sensoriais
e etc
o outro caminho é o uso de tablets
esses de interface de toque para o
ensino visual da palavra e da escrita
digital deixando de lado a estrutura
fonética das palavras ea escrita cursiva
manual
nesse em relação ao primeiro caso eu
queria dizer o primeiro caminho que nós
temos resultados com o canabidiol é
nosso grupo e outros grupos muito
promissores
em relação ao segundo caso queria
apresentar para vocês o segundo caminho
é o litro com o litro é um pacote de
aplicativos é desenhados para o ensino
inclusivo é e inclusivo da linguagem
escrita e o ensino do uso das palavras
para o pensamento o electro ele é
composto por vários módulos cada módulo
usa estratégias estratégias diferentes
uma das estratégias usadas por exemplo é
usar a relação do toque com a imagem
para criar um vínculo funcional entre as
palavras e os respectivos significados
ou seja as palavras são aprendidas
inteiras como ícones depois que elas são
aprendidas então esses ícones eles podem
ser reconstruídos através do arraste de
pecinhas com letras ou com as sílabas e
eventualmente é com o uso de teclados
adaptados também existem módulos em que
existem jogos que estimulam o uso mental
de palavras
além disso todo o sistema é consegue
registrar não apenas o desempenho do
usuário nas tarefas propostas mas a
própria interação dele com a interface
como ele interage com aquilo tudo isso é
registrado e pode ser usado para o time
usar a interface para cada indivíduo
para otimizar o método como um todo e
pode transformar é esse sistema numa
ferramenta para pesquisa e otimizar
digamos uma uma neuropedagogia inclusiva
específica para esse tipo de para cada
indivíduo na verdade bem esse aqui é o
quintal e meu filho é autista e não
verbal que este ano ao completar 11 anos
coincidentemente a mesma idade da califa
chan
ele se comunicou pela primeira vez e no
dia ea primeira vez que ele
espontaneamente se aproximou para tirar
algo que estava na mente dele e dizer o
que era eu estava sentado no computador
e aí ele assumiu o teclado e começou a
escrever a letra por letra a de eventos
assim mesmo em inglês sem copiar nem
olhando aquilo assombrado que que nunca
vi isso e parece aceitar psicografando
um espírito gringo e depois que eu fui à
medida que eu fui me recuperando eu fui
entendendo do que é que ele estava
falando
ele está falando de um de uma série que
a gente gosta muito de assistir juntos
só temos em inglês inglês é the great
adventure off n embutidos nas grandes
aberturas dn beto e é uma série que a
gente gosta muito triste assistir junto
e toda vez que eu assisto esse episódio
especificamente eu digo pra ele que eu
acredito que a próxima grande aventura
da humanidade
não vai ser a descoberta de vida
inteligente fora da terra vai ser o
contato profundo com o fascinante
universo da mente autista não verbal
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]